the coloring book has entertained
children for generations providing a
gentle non-challenging activity to while
away the hours now coloring books are
enjoying a resurgence with three of this
week's top sellers on amazon being
coloring in books for grown-ups so why
are those well into double figures
sharpening coloring pencils and staying
neatly within the lines well coloring in
helps us de-stress and self express with
some books even labeling themselves as
art therapy the sudden surge in adult
coloring in has been somewhat tributed
to our current fascination with
mindfulness a form of meditation which
at its simplest involves focusing on the
present these books let us get lost in
magical worlds and designs providing an
old-school opportunity to switch off
they don't involve phones tablets or
computers and with the average brick
spending a depressing 6.7 hours staring
at a screen each day this is a
refreshing feature experts say that
coloring in comms an overactive mind due
to engaging the brain enough to stop it
worrying but not so much that the
concentration is draining but I have a
feeling that it works simply because it
makes us feel like kids again so why
don't we show our true colors and dig
out those crayons to reveal the big kid
inside all of us silver lining you might
just feel a little more chilled out in
the process
you